hi friends so nice to see you back for
today's Meetup if we haven't had a
chance to meet yet and this is your
first Meetup I'm Rachel I'm calling in
from Boston today actually at the r city
office in Seaport it's so nice to meet
you and to see so many familiar names
joining as well
feel free to introduce yourselves
through the chat window and say hello as
well I love getting to see where people
are calling in from all over the world
and also to be able to see people
sharing helpful resources with each
other over there in the chat as well
I host these meetups every Tuesday at
noon eastern time and they are all
recorded and shared up to the r studio
YouTube as well if you want to go check
out past sessions too
I'll say this one will be the recording
will be up immediately at the same exact
YouTube live link
but this is a friendly Meetup
environment for teens to share different
use cases with each other and teach
lessons learned
together we're all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
you can add the whole calendar or
individual events to your own calendar
with a link
I will show on the screen here right now
for a heads up about next week we will
be back here same place for a talk on
beautiful reports and presentations with
Cordo and the following week a talk on
model monitors and alerting at scale
with rstudio connect
today we are so lucky to be joined by
both Julia silgi and Isabelle Zimmerman
presenting on ML Ops with vetiver in
Python and r
during the event you can ask questions
on YouTube live or LinkedIn wherever
you're watching from and are also able
to ask anonymous questions as well
through the short link that I will put
up here on the screen
and so we will try to answer as many
questions as possible from there but
with that I would love to put Paul Julia
and Isabelle up here on our virtual
stage with me
hello how are you doing
doing well how are you good thank you
for being here with us I'm excited to
turn it over to you and Isabel I'll pull
your screen on stage
there we go
awesome well hello everyone we are so
excited to see you all here for the
nlots with vetiver in Python and our uh
Meetup today and talking about beautiful
uh quarto presentations is next week
this is a quarto presentation I love
plugging that it's my favorite thing
um and so who are we I am Isabel
Zimmerman I am a open source ml op
software engineer here at rstudio and
I'm joined here today with Julia silke
who is also an open source software
engineer writing great analops tools um
in R and I write them in Python
but another important question is who
are you so who's joining here today we
have a slido poll question for you all
what language does your team use for
machine learning so Julie and I have
worked really hard to make sure that
vetiver feels great for bilingual data
science teams so that's data science
teams that are writing in both R and
python but it also feels like a great
native experience if you are just an R
user or just a python user
so if you're developing a model
you can operationalize that model
and in fact we believe that you likely
should operationalize that model
which gives us a really big looming
question of what is operationalization
what is ml Ops
and if you're here you're probably on
some sort of mlops Journey whether
you're just curious about what it is or
maybe digging into tools
and the MLS landscape looks a little bit
like this there's a lot of pieces going
around is it infrastructure is it
analytics is it open source are we
looking at apis and it makes us feel
sometimes a little bit like this
but there is
um kind of a one-liner everyone finds
envelopes a little differently
but the way that we see analops is as a
set of practices to deploy and maintain
machine learning models in production
reliably and efficiently all of those
tools are helping you do this in some
way
and Emma lopsis not something you can
pass off to your I.T Department we
believe that data scientists should be
owning part of this process
so there are great tools out there to
help you through that data science life
cycle we have another quick slido pull
for what packages are you guys using the
most from machine learning right now
we know there's
um great ways to collect data to
understand and clean data on the r side
that's tools like the Tidy verse or
Theta table
on the python side it's maybe super or
pandas or numpy once your data is
cleaned and understood you are ready to
train and evaluate a model once again on
the r side you're looking at tools like
carrot or tidy models or in Python
things like Pi torch or scikit-learn
but then you enter kind of the wild west
of mlops and it's sometimes hard to find
um you know ml Ops open source tools
that fit your needs and vetiver is
really well scoped into helping data
scientists version deploy and monitor
their models
and we'll take a little bit of a closer
look in what we mean when we use those
three verbs
so mlaps is versioning
it's managing change in models it's
going to help you avoid the pitfalls of
you know
model final and then model final one and
then like model final it's actually this
one so it helps you scale your models
but it also will help you organize your
models and share your models by giving
them context more robust versioning and
a little bit of metadata so you can kind
of manage you know your production
versus your staging environments so you
make sure your models are well organized
mlops is deploying and this is a loaded
question in slido we have for you have
you ever deployed a model
deploying can mean different things to
different people
but it might have actually been
something you've done before and didn't
even realize it whenever you're taking a
model out of the environment that it's
been trained in and you're putting it in
some other computational environment you
can say that is deployment so things
like putting a model in a shiny app are
deploying but we really believe that
um stable models are models that are in
rest apis so this is an individual
computational environment that just
hosts your model at uh an API endpoint
so it is independent of maybe a larger
application it makes it faster and
easier and a little bit more robust to
just Host this model by itself and not
inside of an application
and analapse is monitoring
this is tracking model performance
so if you are not monitoring your model
you might be immune to if your model is
performing poorly and that's because
models can fail silently it can be at
zero percent accuracy and still spitting
out predictions left and right
um so you really have to be tracking
this model performance so you can tell
when things are going wrong
so
what does this look like when you're
using vetiver
so we can see our data science life
cycle over here once again we know data
scientists have effective tools to do
this half of the data data science
lifecycle but maybe need some more
support on the other half
so we're going to start by building a
model
we're going to load in some environment
variables and we're going to make this
model to predict uh what Scooby-Doo
episodes have a real monster and which
ones have a fake monster
we're going to load in some data in the
arrow format and we're going to do our
pre-processing and fitting our model
and we're going to put these two things
together in a pipeline and deploy them
as a whole
and the way we're going to be able to
deploy these models is using a
Deployable model object called a vetiver
model now notice this is the first place
that vetivers come into the life cycle
so you get to use those same tools that
you're very familiar with and this is
kind of just an extension of your
current workflow
so the studever model will take in the
pipeline I'll give my model a name and
then I'll feed it a little bit of my
training data to kind of prime the API
endpoint that way when new data comes in
my API endpoint can check to make sure
it looks the same way that the model
expects it to
so next we're going to version our model
and vetiver actually has a secret weapon
called pins and pins is something that
helps you create boards that you can
write data but also models to and it
will automatically version your model in
a really robust way
so we can see our version right here
we've pinned this board to RS connect or
our studio connect but this would just
as easily be bored S3 or Azure or even
just a local folder
and the rest of it pretty much looks the
exact thing
so when we write our model we have a
little prompt that says model cards
provide a framework for responsible
recording
model cards are something that there
have been a lot of research on that have
a really holistic view on deploying a
model
uh inside of edifer there is a template
that'll get you like 80 of the way to a
model card you can see inside this card
you get to document things like metrics
and
um evaluation data but also things like
maybe ethical considerations or caveats
and recommendations so you can really
show your knowledge and all that
information that you've used and
generated when you're making your model
so we can generate our model card
template here and now we will deploy our
model that is versioned it is ready to
be deployed
but before it's deployed somewhere else
we need to make sure it's working
locally
so here we can use our fediver API
and set up our API and click run
and
we will see in the browser all of this
is automatically generated by vetiver
um to have a visual documentation at
your API endpoint we can see the server
it's running locally we get a little bit
of information of what kind of model it
is
the name of the model a health endpoint
and then we get to the predict endpoint
so we can try it here to make sure that
this API is working as we expect it to
uh let's not look at the year zero but
maybe the year 2000 and this Scooby-Doo
has an IMDb rating of eight
and it's probably a fake monster in this
Scooby-Doo episode
but of course this is not our end goal
our end goal is not to have our model
running on a local machine but somewhere
else
so
this is
um looking at deploying this to RS
connect
so vetiver has a kind of one liner here
to deploy to connect we're feeding it in
a connect server the board that we've
specified earlier and the pin name that
we just created we can also specify a
version if we want this API linked to a
single version
um to kind of quickly iterate on that uh
that version that exists
so I've already deployed this model
let's just make a prediction from this
that's living up in our demo server
cloud
will create a vetiver endpoint
and let's generate some new episodes
and we'll predict with this model by
feeding in the new episodes and the
connect endpoint
so this can really feel like it's a
model that is inside your computational
environment even though I'm connecting
to something that's out on a cloud
somewhere else it's on a different
server and this is doing the kind of
data frame to Json
to API server to Json back to data frame
feeling for you
so you don't have to do any of the Json
gymnastics
and we can get these predictions back in
a data frame format
um so it feels really natural
even though this is not a model that's
even on this machine
once this model is deployed you're going
to be continuing to update
um some metrics you're going to be
collecting kind of the dates you're
making these predictions so we're going
to read in some validation data that has
you know the date that the model the
model was making these predictions
and we're going to feed this into a
vetiver DOT compute metrics function
we'll give it the data the date variable
a period and it'll do kind of a Time
series
um computation of the metrics so you can
track these over time this is for the F1
score but it could just as easily be
accuracy or any metric set that is
available
then we will take these Scooby metrics
we've just created and used the built-in
plot function it looks a little small
since we only have these three data
points or three years of data and we're
aggregating year over year
but you can make this as extensible and
as complex as you want
um adding you know loads of data and
multiple different metrics to track
and I think with that we have gone
through the entire data science life
cycle and just about 5-10 minutes
um and this is what vetiver looks like
in Python so I'm going to pass this over
to Julia to show you what it looks like
in r
fantastic thank you so much for that
Isabel um that's such a great
introduction to what it is that we're
talking about and just to put this up
here again just to re reiterate
um once more what where vetiver sits in
the model
um like what we'll call the ml app cycle
and what are the tasks that it does like
uh um the under an underlying assumption
or driving design
um uh decision for vetiver is that these
things on the right hand side
um you you have great open source tools
that you like to use for those and is
over here on the left hand side that
vetiver comes in and you can use to
connect what you've already done here
through to that kind of ml Ops task like
versioning your model deploying your
model and then monitoring your model so
let's see what that looks like
um what that looks like in R
um I do I want to highlight the the name
a little bit because I think it's a
helpful metaphor so vetiver if you're
like really into
um
perfume our scented candles you may have
seen or heard the word vetiver as an
ingredient because it's a stabilizing
ingredient in
um in in perfumery it takes the more
volatile fragrances stabilizes them so
that your you know perfume can last a
long time so in this you know in this
analogy your models are these like more
volatile really valuable fragrances and
what vetiver does is stabilizes it so
that you can deploy with confidence so
let's look at the same data on
Scooby-Doo episodes and here um in our
we're going to
um load this uh Arrow data set so this
whoops let's make sure I'm in the right
place
there we go okay so the um this Scooby
Do data set is originally from tidy
Tuesday but we transformed it a little
bit and saved it as an arrow file so
that both on the Python and the r side
we can read it in in the same way so it
has um this this thing we're going to
predict whether the monster is fake or
real in a certain episode the year that
it aired
um what the IBM DB rating was and then
we got the title and as well so we can
we can keep a track of that so this kind
of picture us here doing Eda using some
tool that you like like pandas or um the
Tidy verse
um now let's go so that's you know we
just did some things over here and this
understand and clean the data now let's
move on to training and evaluating a
model so here I'm going to use a a
support Vector Machine model so let's
set up that support Vector machine
specification and now I'm going to make
a um a feature engineering recipe here
so support Vector machines it turns out
you have to do some data pre-processing
him so to them so what and then I'm
going to combine the feature
pre-processing together with the model
into a workflow and fit it to the data
that I have so so what I want you to
notice here is that um I'm I'm going to
be able to what I'm doing is I'm using
good statistical practices treating my
pre-processing together with my modeling
and and I can take that whole thing and
move on to my mlops task
so again um from before everything I've
shown you so far we want you to keep
using the tools that you know and love
that you think are I'm a good fit for
your particular use case now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to I'm going to
start using vetiver so just like on the
python side you know we read data in
maybe did some Eda train to model and
now it's time for us to um start going
into the ml Ops tasks so the first thing
that we'll do here is that we'll use
um vetiver to create a Deployable model
object so I'll
um
I will get this so it's not quite so
close to the end I want you to notice
what's printed out here because the idea
of like why why why do I need to make a
Deployable model object is because at
the time of training your model you have
a lot of information about it you know
for example
um like whether it was a classification
model or a regression model you know
like what kind of computational engine
you use to train it with you know how
many features there were and what the
names and data types were of those
features that went into your model and
the reason why you wanted to play you
want to use vetiver to create this kind
of Deployable model object is that it is
designed so that it collects and Stores
um uh all the information you need to
make predictions in a new computational
environment
um at training time because you know you
have all that information let's store it
in a nicely organized package bundle
um so that you can then take it
somewhere else so just like Isabelle was
saying that um when like the the a good
way to think about have I deployed a
model is um have you taken a model that
was in one computational environment and
put it somewhere else so that it can
integrate with your it infrastructure
that so that's what this is getting
ready here for us to do
all right so we have our ready to go
model object Deployable model object and
now I'm going to version slash publish
slash share my model so I'm going to use
pens to do this and I right now am going
to you can see from my screen here that
I've connected to our demo
um connect server and I am going to
write my vetiver model there so this is
um this is uh pins are have have support
for many different kinds of
infrastructures upon which to version
share publish models so just like on the
python side and the r side you can write
to connect you can write to
um S3 buckets at AWS S3 buckets you can
write to like like an Azure blob storage
you can write to a network drive if
that's the way that your particular
organization works the important thing
is that the pinning works the same
um and the um and it allows you this
nice a little bit of you know uh
usability in terms of I need to get a
versioned uh I need to store this in a
versioned way on my um uh to keep my
model somewhere that like is the
appropriate place for my particular
infrastructure
um so I want to just highlight here
again that
um I got a little prompt that I get uh
once per session about that reminding me
to create a model card so I am going to
show you in
um in R how you might go about doing
that so if I if I um go to say I want to
make a new our markdown I've got a
couple of things here in um in that are
vetiver templates so one of them is this
model card and what this does is just
like Isabelle said this can get you like
80 percent of the way there to
documenting your model with a model card
so if you haven't heard or read about
model cards this paper I encourage you
to look at it this is really great it
explains what they are and what this
does is it goes through for example
um and things that can be automated like
hey we we know what kind of model this
is we know what version we're using um
we can automate those parts and then it
provides you an outline to the parts
that take human domain knowledge to be
able to answer so like what are the uses
of this model
um why why did you choose the metrics
that you did so it allows you to walk
through and do a good job of documenting
your model in a appropriate and specific
way
um great Okay so we've versioned our
model we have
um uh we have thought about how we're
going to document our model and now it's
time for me to
um deploy the model as a rest API so
here I am going to run this
um I'm going to run this locally where I
am going to see oh right look I I can
create a I can create a um a rest API
that's going to run locally on my my
machine right here so this is this is
running in this R session notice that my
R session is kind of busy right now
because it's serving this um this API to
me and I can understand I can locally
debug it takes me this many lines three
lines of code to locally debug the model
to be able to see like what is what is
it doing like okay I've got you know
like my my health check endpoint and
then I've got my prediction endpoint
here right and I can interact with this
so let's say
there was
um let's say it's the year 1990 and
something has an idea ibmb rating of 8.3
I can I can literally like interact with
my model
um locally here and I can you know like
I I can understand like what what does
it need to
um like what does it look like when I
interact with say I'll do you know batch
prediction and tell me like oh okay both
of those are fake both of those are fake
monsters and it also as I'm interacting
with this I I get the curl like it shows
me the curl so think of this interactive
documentation as a tool for you as the
model developer to
um to be able to uh understand debug
figure out how your model is working and
also as a tool for collaborating with
um other people in your organization
um uh data Engineers
um uh it infrastructure people sres if
anyone needs to know how do I interact
with your model you can show them you
can show them directly here
so I am going to stop this little local
um
little local uh uh API that was running
in my R session and then I'm going to
talk about okay that's good for local
debugging how do I get it from my
computer into a new computational
environment which is exactly
um what we you know what we're talking
about what we want to do here so we have
a um if you want to deploy your models
to connect we have a one-liner
um function that will that will take
your where you have stored your model
what which model it is and it will
um
with with that one function deploy it to
connect so we have support for this
um for this like really smooth sort of
push button very simple kind of
deployment to connect we also have
support for other
um for deploying to other kinds of
targets say you want to deploy to
sagemaker you want to deploy on a
different AWS way of serving things you
want to deploy
um on Azure or some other Target then we
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to learn
um you're going to want to deploy using
Docker so to make a Docker container for
vetiver
you are going to want to
um first generate a plumber file so this
is what the generated plumber files look
like like I like we run this line right
here and it makes a file that looks like
this
um so this file uh you know it it is
something that is editable by you if you
have some sort of higher like more
complex use case but the default you
know serves most people's use cases
pretty well so so this gets generated
here and then what I'll do is I will
write here let me delete this so you can
tell me I can show you what it makes so
let me delete the one that I did when I
was practicing okay it's gone and let me
um come over here and I'm I'm going to
write my Docker file here so it is so
what's happening right now is it's
looking at the model V that I have this
Deployable model object it's saying okay
what um what packages says do I need to
install into the docker container
to be able to make predictions so for
example this just to give you like a
little bit of a like a Insight of like
what does that mean the packages that
you might need
um uh if you tuned your model
um you don't need the tuning
infrastructure when you deploy you only
need the part the packages that are
required to make a prediction so and
that's what what's happening so we we
made when it was like okay let me
generate this Docker file for you it
updated this this lock file and then it
made this Docker file so this is what I
just made by running that um by running
that function so it will it's it looked
at exactly the version of r that I'm
using right now it's going to use the
public package manager to install
binaries that are fast which is good and
then it knows exactly which
um uh software dependencies it needs
like system dependencies what do we need
to install in there and then it will use
it will use the um this rm.lock file
that I made which I'll just show you
what that looks like this is a this is a
uh
standardized format for saying what
packages you have exactly what version
of it do you have where did you install
it from and so forth so so it is going
to use that lock file to
um install all those packages copy the
plumber file over and then this part is
what happens when the um
when the docker file is run so if we go
over here I'm not going to run this
right now because it takes a little
while this is probably the slowest part
of anything that we're showing you here
um building a Docker file can
um can
um the reason that it takes a little bit
is it's setting up a whole computational
environment like a whole little mini
computer and so it installs everything
so the keys to making it faster to build
your Docker containers are um be very
careful about
um what you're installing in there that
you're only installing what you need to
to keep them getting too bloated so I'm
going to go so Docker is not a tool you
use an r or python but rather a tool you
use on the terminal so I'm going to go
over here to the terminal I I'm gonna I
pre-built this so I use this exactly
here if you're looking at this bit
the reason I'm using that is that I um
the machine that I'm using right now is
a is a Mac M1 which is a different kind
of chip like a different kind of chip
than an Intel chip and the um most
places you want to take a Docker
container don't use Arm chips they use
Intel chips so if you're going to build
your Docker container locally and you're
on like a newer Mac one of the M1 or M2
chips then you want to use this so that
the docker
container that you build can go
somewhere else and be be deployed on
that infrastructure it also means we can
um we can use the binaries that are
built by the package manager which are
built for Intel chips so I so I did this
ahead of time it took
I don't know five minutes
something like that for me to build this
and but now what I can do is I can run
it so I am going to in this
is this where let me
yeah okay so I'm gonna run this here
notice uh let's talk about a couple of
things here
I'm passing in um an environment file a
file of environment variables so the
whatever Docker container you have for
this to work successfully it has to be
able to authenticate to where the binary
model object is where this thing where
the model is kept so if you look at the
plumber file it's reading here right
like from wherever the like where is
that model I need to get to that model
so um a good way to do that is via
environment variables I'm also
connecting the port on the inside to the
port on the outside and then this is the
name of the one that I'm running so
let's start this off so first it's
telling me hey you're actually on arm
and this was built like to be a pretend
computer this may not be as fast as it
could be otherwise which is very true
and now now it's running now it's
running so let me
um let me
um uh uh
talk about what I can happen next I can
visit this in a browser in fact I will
um
I will click on this so that it can
um so that I can show you what that
looks like here in a moment but I also
can interact with it from r
so so right now the docker container is
running and so on the little whoops the
little local Port
um
here on my computer I can interact with
that directly from R so this is what it
would look like if you were interacting
with the model from python or R but it
is it is somewhere else it's not here
locally so I create something called a
vetiver endpoint so notice that the um
this right now is just looking at my own
little local computer but this could be
an endpoint anywhere I can take that
that's that's kind of the point of
Docker is we take this thing I build it
it is self-contained and I can take it
where it needs to go so if this is this
could be
um on a cloud platform this could be on
a server that I have somewhere I've
taken that Docker container and I've
moved it somewhere that is useful to me
so now let's say I have some some new
episodes so I'm gonna
um let's see what do those look like I'm
just kind of I'm just generating so I'm
like pretend Scooby-Doo episodes and I
can
um predict from my endpoint whether
those episodes are real or are fake and
I passed the data and what's happening
here is that I I it looks like I'm just
treating that endpoint like it's a model
in memory like either in python or R
this is set up so that you just call
predict like a predict method or a
predict function the way that you're
used to but what this is doing actually
is it's taking your data that's like a
data frame it's converting it to Json
making an HTTP call getting Json back
and converting it back into a nice data
frame format that you have because so
that you as a model developer can
quickly iterate on
um the the using the tools that you are
most comfortable with the tools that you
like the best data frames
um predicting all that type of thing
okay so so far we've talked about
versioning the model we've talked about
um deploying the model and now let's
talk about monitoring the model so what
vetiver will monitor has functions to
help you monitor the statistical
properties of your model over time so to
do that you need new data that has
labels so let's say we have uh let's say
we're able to look into the future and
there are some new Scooby-Doo
um episodes that are coming out starting
in 2023 and I somehow happen to
magically have the data now notice to to
monitor the statistical properties of
how your model is doing you have to have
the the answers the labels that often
means you have some kind of feedback
loop that may be very short or maybe a
little bit longer but often in many
situations we do have that feedback loop
and it is what we need in order to
monitor
um that sort of the gold standard for
how are we going to tell if our mod if
our if our model is performing the way I
want to
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to compute some metrics
um uh over a certain time aggregation so
we have like 100 future Scooby-Doo
episodes here and we're going to
aggregate it at that what I want to
um highlight is that um uh models can
use time in different ways so this
particular model actually uses the year
as one of the features
um and that happens sometimes sometimes
your model uses some kind of date time
quantity as a feature so in this case
we're using the year and that um that is
you know sometimes you do that
monitoring always involves some kind of
date time quantity so we've got this
here in a date aired
um variable like a day aired column that
we have so that that is not that does
not necessarily have to mean it's a
feature in the model but it's the
dimension along which we are monitoring
so monitoring always involves us over
time collecting new
um validation data you might call it or
monitoring data you might call it that
has
um the labels that we have it so that we
can we can um uh compute and uh monitor
how our modeling is doing over time so
let's come over here so first I'm just
going to show you what it looks like if
I use augment so I can augment on a um
using a vetiver model and what this does
is it lets me predict and bind columns
together so we've got all this data that
we had before and then a predicted class
using this vetiver model that I have in
memory here and once we have this where
we have you know the variables that
we're interested in like monitoring over
uh the predictions then we can use this
vetiver compute metrics function
here which will um how use it use it
supports sliding metrics quite complex
Windows along which to
um Aggregates and it will
um set that up for us to uh compute the
metrics that we're interested in so I'm
going to say this is the
um the variable over which I am
monitoring uh this is the aggregation
unit that I'm using I want to aggregate
at the year level and then here are the
the things I'm going to use for
computing metrics like what the what are
the variables there so I'm gonna so here
I now have computed my metric so I have
for each year in this data set 2023 2024
2025 I have
um n is how many episodes there are so
we've got you know 20 to 40 episodes and
then a metric here
um so that's computed
um using the the support that vetiver
has for
um the common use cases for monitoring
statistical metrics over time the
statistical performance of your model
over time
on the um
like on the python side
um on the r side we have support for
um plotting metrics for pinning metrics
uh if you want to use pins which we
recommend to store the aggregated
metrics over time and so we have a just
a default way of making a plot that
probably will work for you but it is
just data so here I show just making
like a um uh like like a like a custom a
custom kind of graph visualization
showing us how the metrics are doing
over time so um this is so a a design
um consideration for vetiver is that we
provide functions that account for the
most common use cases but all of these
components are extensible for more
custom needs more advanced use cases so
if I I'm like I don't want to use that
um that default plot uh approach I want
to make my own plots
um and and um I can do that because this
is all you know data here so here the
ACT this you know it's like oh in this
case accuracy looks pretty good and
Kappa you know estimates how well the
results you are getting agree with what
you would expect and it takes into
account the class imbalance so you know
in the 2023 and 2024 it looks like this
uh it you know agrees about as much as
we expect in 2025 it's like oh it's
agreeing a little better maybe than we
would have when then maybe we would have
expected
um so this is a monitoring example where
we just have three monitoring points
um but a uh if you are clicking through
I encourage you to see this more
realistic monitoring example I'm going
to show you what it looks like so I am
again going to go to make a new our
markdown file I'm going to go to the
templates and I'm going to go down and
I'm going to pick this dashboard so what
this dashboard is is it is a again like
a template to get you 80 of the way
there for more complex
um model monitoring
um it's it is uh so a vetiver dashboard
is a special it builds on top of a flex
dashboard in um on the r side and it
lets you use parameters to say where is
my model what is my model called
um how do I want to you know like I can
style this because this Builds on all
top of all the you know beautiful
dashboard that already exists in our
and what if we want to look here at what
happens the um we have a dashboard so
this dashboard provides like a like a
opinionated sort of set of advice of how
to set up a monitoring dashboard that
will
um keep track of your statistical
performance of your model over time uh
plot something uh plot you know metrics
like you might expect in using functions
that we provide and then also it is it
is
um code that is generated and so you can
extend this in the way that is
appropriate to your use case you can add
in different plots you can add in tables
you can also like plop in that API
visual documentation that you have there
to be able to share this as a artifact
that people can understand not not only
data practitioners in your organization
but software engineering folks it folks
can understand how the model works and
how to enter interact with it
alright so I am going to
um go back to the slides
and share this and so this this is the
um
Docker
um file that is running this is that so
I can actually visit in the docker file
in a browser as well but I'll go back
over to these slides so so in these
demos what we did was we started with um
Python and then we went to R and we
showed you how to how to
um uh walk through these different kinds
of ml Ops tasks so yeah um I hope that
what this did was show you
um that that ml Ops doesn't have to be
um uh there are many tools out there but
at its core the what ml Ops is is a set
of practices that you can learn and you
can adopt that deploy and maintain the
the models that you build in production
which remember we said was like in a
different computational environment
where it's going to interact with
different parts of your infrastructure
and that the set of practices that are
here are to set you up so that your
models that you have are um are reliable
and that you're you're efficient in
these practices without
um that they work well for you to keep
this this
um these systems up and running in a
reliable and inefficient way
so as a as a wrap up so
um there's a lot of tools out there that
do a lot of different kinds of things so
what vetiver does is it allows you to
bring
um the your your existing modeling
um uh preferences and uh how how you
like to build models and it provides for
support for you to version your model in
a robust way so that you can identify
which versions of models are in use at
any given time so that you can do ad hoc
analyzes get to previous versions
without rolling back whole deployment
environments speaking of which vetiver
provides support for you to deploy your
model
um say using
um using something like push button or
single functions to deploy on connect or
using Docker to go to Cloud platforms or
servers of your own and vetiver provides
support for you to monitor your models
to to understand record summarize and
visualize the statistical properties of
your model over time
and so vetiver is built from the ground
up to work for for both R and python
models this means it's a really good fit
for
um bilingual data science teams where
people use r or python use both R and
python in those teams or even if you as
an individual sometimes reach for R and
sometimes reach for python when you're
building statistical machine learning
models that means vetiver is a good fit
because you you uh use the same approach
for both and you can support your team
either can be supported in making the
best choices for them individually or
you yourself you know can be like ah
well it I can train my model however I
want and then I will be able to deploy
it in a way that makes sense in my
organization and is consistent no matter
what I use to deploy the model so we've
got our last
um
our last
um uh poll on slido so if you're if
you're on um a slido and you click over
to the polls tab you can see this pop-up
and we're we're really interested in
what kinds of models you often use so
this has overlap maybe with the question
about software
um but what we're what we're interested
in here is more um like do you use a lot
of deep learning models do you use a lot
of tree based models you use
um are you know are you currently
um uh uh spending a lot of time you know
using
um uh uh Gams or something like that
like what kind of models do you often
use so vetiver right now has support for
um
um I would say on the order of now like
a dozen different kinds of models
including all of scikit-learn all of
Tidy models
um like a lot of a lot of the big ones
but we certainly are interested in what
are the common use cases that you have
or that you want to pursue more and to
make sure we are supporting people
people's um most common use cases there
um so like so yeah so I said this
already so vetiver
um works on our Studios pro products
like connect and then also works um in a
you know public or private cloud or
server using using docker
um so we are super excited about having
gotten to share this with you
um today but we encourage you if you
want to get started with us to to learn
more so um the first place we recommend
that you look is the our documentation
site at
vetiver.rstudio.com so this is
um this is a bilingual documentation
site where you can go to learn about R
and or python together
um I encourage you to check out
Isabelle's talk from our studio conf
this past summer uh it's the one that's
called demystifying ml Ops if you're
looking at the slides yourself and
locally you can just click that link and
I'll take it right to you and um I this
one is fun it's instead of Scooby-Doo
it's all about cookies and using cookies
and baking as a um uh as a illustration
to understand what Emma lops is
if you want to see more about how to use
Docker
um especially if you're newer to using
Docker I did a recent screencast on how
to deploy a model with Docker and then
also there are some really great
end-to-end demos from
um from are the solutions engineering
team at our studio and there's there's
one for R and one for python that uses
the same kind of data on bike shares and
how to predict how many bikes will be
um are used in different situations and
what is great about those is it is it is
really end to end they're they're fairly
extensive and they show you how to go
from uh how to retrain a model on a
schedule how to uh integrate a model
into an interactive shiny app so that
you can um so it's really end to end
which is a great way to look at that and
with that I will stop sharing and we
will
um see if we can use the rest of our
time to answer a few questions
awesome thank you so much Julia and
Isabelle I see a lot of
clapping and saying great job in the
chat awesome work a lot of people really
excited about diving into this
there are also a ton of questions on
both slido and through YouTube here so
if you don't mind me throwing a lot of
these at you I'd love to jump in let's
do this awesome so I see I see Stefan hi
Stefan asked a question on YouTube can
you make vetiver refuse to make
predictions that are outside your
applicability domain
so this would be an example of
um of like an advanced use case that we
kind of alluded to so the um the the
auto-generated like plumber files
um uh have like the predict endpoint but
you can write functions in there and you
can add other endpoints that um that
adjust or change right like what is
served at an endpoint or might be what
may be served at another endpoint so
some examples of things that we know
people
um can use this for and that fit
people's use cases are um for example
like an explainability score like like
let's serve a prediction let's serve in
that
um a um an explainability score along
with that prediction and and the other
one would be something like uh
unapplicability score so you can either
serve the applicability score or you can
change like write a function to change
what is served so that you check it and
then do or do not serve it so the way
you would go about doing that would be
um uh realizing like okay this is a more
advanced use case I am going to need to
go into that plumber file and
um
and adjust it or on the python side into
that app.pi and be able to
um write write a function that will be a
Handler effectively but we have support
for all that and testing that it works
and all that type of thing
awesome thank you I see this is one of
the most upvoted questions on slido and
sorry it makes me split it up in two
lines here but can you deploy models
using Docker and Cloud environments such
as AWS can you pass custom Docker images
that fit your organization's security
and architecture
Isabel do you want to answer that one or
yeah I can grab that one
um the short answer is yes uh the docker
files that vetiver generates are just
code so any customization that you need
to put in there uh to fit that
organization security if they have
custom Docker images
um you can update all of that in the
docker file itself and you can take
Docker files to cloud environments such
as AWS or gcp or azure
yeah as an example like one thing that
is currently in a PR on the our our side
for vetiver is like specific support for
deploying as a Lambda function and so
what the reason I bring this up is
because it's like it's a special kind of
Docker container like you have to add a
runtime and stuff like that versus
starting with the like a base image
that's like python or base image this R
it's like a special you know base image
for Lambda functions and so because we
have that we're taking this approach
that is
um generate code account for this use
case and then let it be extensible we
actually can even support some of these
more extensible things directly in the
software
great thank you
um another question I'm going to go back
and forth between YouTube and slido here
one question from Tony was this may be
more of a plumber question but how do
you make the predictions directly in the
browser is there particular syntax to
pass arguments via the URL
um so if this is a question about the
interactive documentation that we showed
um and how we're like we're directly
interacting in a browser with the models
you know things are going past in
um in the post requests and then we're
seeing what's coming back that's because
of the um open API specification so
vetiver in the python side and the r
side
um creates model aware model appropriate
open API specifications so that when you
have your API created via under the hood
fast API on the python side or plumber
on the r side
um you you're getting something that
that is aware of the domain that you're
working in so that um so the the making
predictions directly in the browser like
we showed is because of the uh
customization of the open API
specification that that ever provides on
both sides
thank you another question on on slido
is is there an e-book for vetiver
similar to the one we have for tidy
models
is it all you want to answer that
there is not there are a lot of great
resources out there for nlops in general
um we just had kind of like an internal
book club and we went through chip ones
um designing ml applications
guess the name of it
um so there are great books out there
for mlops but not anything that is kind
of very specific
I do think the the set of uh resources
like documentation that we have is
getting pretty robust so
um this is something what we're that's a
priority for us you know this fall and
moving forward to get even more
documentation especially for advanced
use cases but I do think that
um although not probably like a whole
book worth of content what we have at
vetiver.rstudio.com really really I'm
proud of it I think it gets you pretty a
far far on the path
awesome Isabelle would you be able to
share those the links to those other
books in like the private chat and I
could put them with a recording too
perfect I can do that awesome
um let's see another question over on
YouTube
is
from Marlene um when initially deploying
your ml model how does vetiver handle
data that does not meet the specs of the
training data
do you want to take that one Isabel
I can start with
um if there is an error that occurs
there is really nice error handling that
kind of specifically points you to
exactly what is giving you this error
and what it should be instead that
really leans on that initial p-type so
if you're passing in a date that looks
more like a string or something like
that
um better will point to it and say hey
this is a string but we think it should
be a date or from your P type it should
be a date
yeah and
um
yep that's exactly right and on our side
if we do you want to quickly let me
share my screen again what so so notice
if I pre I predict with good data I get
stuff back but what if I predict with
bad data like like let's say I only have
I only have
um a year aired like I'm missing the
other thing I'll say the year aired is
1990 like that it is going to try to
predict and say oh I should have made
that go with debug equals true okay so
that's actually a really good thing to
to talk about very briefly is it it will
fail to predict and the there's an
option when you um set up your models
you can uh uh allow debugging errors to
come through it's turned off by default
because it can
um provide information about your
training data
um uh when it returns errors and in some
cases that is a privacy issue but in
some cases
um uh you're fine with it and you'd
rather have the better errors so you
have a little bit of a choice there
between I have really tight privacy
constraints constraints around my
training data I need to make sure
nothing is leaked through like none of
that information is leaked
um or you can say okay I would like to
have more informative errors that are
going to um help me see what's going on
so depending on how that um how that
goes uh one way or the other you can uh
you can um get those helpful errors
thank you
um another slido question was
uh let's see plumber also has logging
filters is there any work being done in
vetiver to publish a default logger
alongside new models being deployed for
usage monitoring
um this is something I think will be
interesting for us to look in to look
into more detail we don't have a default
logger currently here you can extend it
in the ways that you extend Other
Plumber
um Other Plumber functions part of this
is because we have been fo we have been
focused on like statistical modeling I'm
assuming this is like those logging
filters that will log here is what the
call was here's the result that you got
here is like somebody made a call with
this in their post data and here is what
we did we sent back
um so right now you can add those to any
um plumber file that you have but
um we don't have a default one that's
model aware so that might be kind of
good for us to look into
I see James asks the question over on
slido Json and apis can be foreign to
those new to model deployment or those
with no web development experience do
you have any advice or resources to
share
I can share
um some more links via this private chat
but I think
uh there are some really good articles I
know
um
that and I think it's best best via link
uh for this one but I think at its core
Json is just kind of a data structure
and I think people get quite scared of
it
um but it's kind of looks like a data
frame if you find a simple Json uh file
and it just expands from there and if
you kind of can contextualize apis as a
Gateway uh that's a good place to start
as well it hangs out independently of
everything else
um but different applications will talk
to it so we're talking to our API that
has a model and then we're getting back
our predictions but on the other side
maybe an application has a standardized
way to talk to this API
um to get back predictions or give them
to customers in a different scenario
um but there is a
there's a lot of great great resources
online as well that we can share links
to
that's right yeah and just to remind
everyone as well the recording for this
uh Meetup will be shared at the exact
same YouTube link that you watch that
and will be made available right away
but we can also share those resources in
the recording details too
okay question on YouTube
hello does it integrate somehow with ML
flow
um so uh if you're interested in
thinking about like
should I choose mlflow or should I
choose vetiver one thing to
um to like a like a main difference
between ml flow and vetiver is that
um vetiver
um is more flexible about what you bring
to the deployment process and ml flow
has more support for because it has more
support for experiment tracking
um it uh wants you to kind of enter into
ml flow earlier however it is true that
you can use these pieces somewhat
composably and so you can
um take you can take the pieces from you
know different ecosystems that and and
get them to work together uh in the way
that's most appropriate for you so um
Isabel do you want to add anything to
that
yeah I think
um my favorite part about this question
is like open source is buffet style you
can take the experiment tracking the ml
flow has invested a lot of time and
effort into
um and then you can pair it with
vetiver's deployment if you prefer that
uh maybe it's easier to make
um like predictions from an endpoint or
it's faster to go from model to API
there so I think it it uh pieces
together quite nicely and you can choose
the pieces that work best for you in
your organization and use them in
conjunction with each other I think
something that we're really excited
about with vetiver is the model to API
time is like two lines of code
um to get a really basic API running so
um that is something that we have spent
a lot of time to make sure it's a great
experience and
um that is a little bit different uh
from mlflow
thank you
you see Marcos asked a question over on
slido are there plans to handle more
complex situations where the request
needs augmentation so for example the
user passes in only the episode title
and the server looks up the year in IMDb
rating
yeah so the um so in either
um so say you wanted to do that this way
um you might want to instead of using
the the vetiver API in that case you
might want to you know set up a little
bit of a a fast API or a polymer API and
then
um and then
you would you would write functions that
did that lookup and then you would um
call the predict function on the vetiver
model so you'd probably like read the
model from where it is
um uh write code that like does the
lookup brings in the data and then call
predict this I can see like uh let's
let's imagine this is a shiny app either
written in python or R the the code of
the shiny app would read the model from
where you have it versioned and stored
and then you would have other code that
would take say the user input look up
what you need and then call predict on
it so this again is
um an example of how these pieces are
composable and extensible to other use
cases why you probably wouldn't use the
vetiver API for this is that the vetiver
API is built to strongly care about the
um the data that's being posted and that
the data that is being posted to the API
matches the features of the model so it
that that's like a strong Assumption of
the vetiver API is that what's getting
posted in the data needs to match the
features
great thank you
um somebody else asked anonymously can
these demo files be made available to
use as references
yes we have the website is up and posted
I was actually presenting from the
website itself
um I think
Rachel you have a short link for that
one yes just trying to go grab it on the
screen real quick
there we go that one is up and it's
running
um we'd love to have other people put
their hands on our material and play
around with whatever
I want to make sure this is the right
length yep that's the right link and so
if you click on
um so there's kind of a main page and
then if you look up at the top on the
right there are both slides and demos so
you can see all the material that we
looked at here today together
and I can see Isabelle backstage pulling
that up too if you wanted to show it
yes
um let me
go
so this is the website you can check out
the slides here you can download the PDF
or view them in a new window
um and then the demos
are available as quarto files for both
Python and r
awesome
and uh if someone from our studio team
wants to help with some of these links
you can copy them over into the YouTube
chat for people too I was gonna do that
but I'm bad at multitasking right now
um
actually I I think we should ask this
question too for people who aren't
um familiar with rest apis what is a
rest API and is there part of our studio
professional products that fulfill this
I am probably not going to give like a
good technical definition of what a rest
API is but I am going to repeat what
Isabelle said where it's like you have
a computer somewhere and it is not
connected to your computer and in on
that other machine you have
um you have a an API which means like
it's a it's a service that will return
things like I I sometimes I think it's
some kind of like functions where it's
like
um either like I can call it I can call
it and it's going to send something back
over to me so maybe it's something where
I like I call it with data like that's
usually that's called a post endpoint
like I post things over to that service
and then it's going to return something
back to me that's different depending on
what I posted sometimes there are
endpoints that are get endpoints where
you just say hey hey and then it will
give you something there's you know more
complex things involved here like query
parameters where you can say to that
service uh I actually want my query to
be slightly like this you know and you
can have changed things via query
parameters but um uh I think the most
important thing to think about are rest
or restful API is that it is a it is a
way to set up a service that can
interact via HTTP calls to other
computers say like your local computer
or Another Part Of Your it
infrastructure so the rstudio pro
product that supports deploying apis in
python or R is our studio connect so
connect can be used to deploy python
apis like via fast API flask vetiver
Builds on top of fast API and in the
rside plumber apis
do you want to add anything to that
Isabelle that was a very fuzzy
non-technical definition of what a rest
API is
no I think that was a great start
um it really is just a way to like for
people or machines to connect
applications whatever an application is
um which is another whole discussion but
um to connect these together in some
sort of standardized way yeah which is
through the open API specifications
which you don't need to know anything
about if you're just learning about refs
apis I wouldn't jump off that um that
diving board
quite yet
there was a quick follow-up question in
slido to that answer about connect and
someone asked is there an rstudio
connect server demo where I could test
whatever
so we have a couple of
um like URLs we can share that have
public facing
um apis that you can look at and or call
Via um uh you know curl or from r or
python so we can get those URLs to share
with you
um uh so
um Rachel if someone was actually
interested in like trying to test out
connect for their own org what would
they do
yes so you can definitely test out
connect for your organization as well
and I could
put the link in the chat to help set up
a call with our team
um so they learn more about your use
case and talk to you about what you're
trying to do
um and I'll put I'll put that in the
YouTube chat
um but also if you're curious if your
org is already using your products and
you might not know that you have them
I'm always happy to help you help
connect you with your account team too
so I can even put my LinkedIn in the
chat as well if you just want to reach
out on there as well
um let's see there was a question that I
saw was upvoted
a few times about GitHub actions let's
see
I assume this works with in a GitHub
action workflow setting up the plumber
or fast API
in creating the docker file then using
these to build in actions
well so certain parts of this we already
run and GitHub actions in various ways
either through Ci or building the docs
that we build so yes absolutely
absolutely this is something that you
can run in GitHub actions and so there
are people who use GitHub actions kind
of as their orchestrator like for their
mlops tools where you say you you say I
want okay let's kick off an action to
train the model and then that will say
maybe in that script it also pins the
model once it's trained and then well
you can kick off a script to say build a
Docker container and then take that
artifact although those get pretty big
um I think it'd be better to write a
Docker file and then if you're going to
say you use AWS or gcp you take that
Docker file and then build it using the
um the container building service of
your Cloud platform of choice and um and
put it in your registry where it goes
awesome I know we're getting to about 15
minutes past the top of the hour
um just wanted to check how many more
questions can I throw at you right now
a couple more sounds good yeah
okay
awesome
um
see I'm not sure if you addressed this
but it was a question on YouTube
do you need to make a Docker file if
you're deploying to connect
nope just the one liner will get you on
the python or our side from your local
environment to connect
awesome thank you
another anonymous question was for model
monitoring can you define custom metrics
instead of predefined metrics
so I'll answer this for the r side and
then Isabella you can answer it for the
python side so yes so the way to do that
on the r side is to create a yardstick
metric so custom metrics in yardstick
involve writing like a function and then
calling like the wrapper and then all
the infrastructure will know ah this is
a metric that I need to aggregate at you
know the same interval that I'm doing
all the other metrics so so I actually
have a blog post about how to write a
yardstick custom metric
um you can take a look for that it is um
it's it's just like writing a little
function and wrapping it in this uh this
wrapper so it's it's not too
straightforward and we know you know we
had no people who like
um like those that ability to extend
with custom metrics is important in many
organizations because you want to
actually say have a metric that has
specific you know business logic in it
or something like that and you want to
be able to optimize and or monitor share
with that directly as well you want to
talk about it for python yeah on the
python side
um you can write any function as long as
it has a like a y true column so the
truth and a predicted value uh it will
compare those to the whatever metric you
are creating
um and return back the value so you are
already able to use custom metrics there
as well
awesome another question can we deploy a
shiny app with vetiver
you sure can
um the link at the end of the slides
with the end-to-end solutions
engineering demo that Julie had shared
uh that is a bike share app that uses
shiny and Jennifer together
um so if you're interested in uh just
clicking around and seeing what it looks
like uh you can hop over to those demo
repos and check it out
awesome I was trying to copy that link
over real quick to post on YouTube as
well I'll put that there in just a
second
uh let me go through to see what we may
have missed
okay a few questions on slido I know we
won't get to everything but I can
definitely share those all with you
Julia and Isabel
uh
one says
okay anonymous question that just came
in most of our models have an ID in the
recipe step which seems to fail in
predictions with vetiver is it best to
remove non-predictor ID columns
um so there have been some updates so
this person is using tidy models with
recipes and is
um uh they have something in their input
that is that is not a predictor
um that they keep around maybe for
diagnosing problems or
um or or uh you know like like analyzing
results like it's something you don't
want to use for prediction but that you
want to
um have and keep in the data set so I
think there's a couple ways you approach
this one is you require it for the input
you say
um you say uh I actually want when this
model is in production I want that ID
and I'm gonna you know record it and use
it for monitoring or something like that
so then you then you make a um uh and I
think that was is what will work by
default the other option is you um when
you go to train a final model like say
in the Tidy model sense you've done lots
of uh tuning and then it's time to do
last fit you you take the ID out and you
retrain it at that point you train it
not retrain it train it without the ID
because you're not going to use it in
production the other option is
um to pass in custom input data
prototype and so here when you create
that vetiver Deployable model object
there's a number of optional arguments
one of them is hey what is the input
data prototype that I'm going to check
against and you can you can
go into your workflow
and pull out the mold and just get the
prediction predictors and then pass that
in and then that is another way so so
the the default behavior is kind of
assumes you have predictors you're going
to end up with a prediction but if you
have a slightly more complex use case
there's these different ways and you can
choose what works best for you
okay two more questions and then I will
let you go thank you so much for
answering all these
um one from Javier on on YouTube was can
you please confirm if the performance
metrics are customizable
um so the metrics that were displayed on
the vetiver HTML export
yes so on the r side it is one of the
arguments to the compute metrics um the
default is to use a default set of
metrics but you can use you know you can
change it you can write your own custom
metrics functions so it is one of the
arguments that goes in there is you need
a metric set function
so on the I think we already said this
but maybe Isabelle just to confirm
yep um the python side also is called
metric set
um and then you'll pass in a list of uh
I normally do psychic learn metrics but
again if it has the Y true and Y
predicted columns that is what this
function is using to make your metric
output
great uh one other question that came in
a few minutes ago on slidos
is vetiver for python as complete as it
is for r
it's a great question do you want to
start Isabel yeah of course so I would
say it is pretty darn close uh we don't
so we think the python side um does not
have the template for the dashboard yet
um but I think everything you saw today
was kind of future parity between the
two languages I don't think we expect to
like be super strict with everything
that's in ours in Python because these
two demographics have different needs
um but we're going to kind of see where
the community takes us
um I guess and see what you know people
are using and really want to help them
with their ml Ops workflows uh in each
language respectively yeah I think
that's right on I mean I think if you're
talking about like is coverage as
complete I think probably so like
depending on like if you were gonna ask
what do people want to use in Python
it's like the coverage is about as
complete in python as are though
everything we showed you today
um uh the coverage is about as complete
there there are pro there are some
things that because the existing machine
learning
um infrastructure is different you know
in the two like the model development
infrastructure is a little different
that things do end up slightly different
and we don't we want we want these to
feel consistent and
um and and to make and like like um that
that someone who is wants to collaborate
with you as a model developer it
basically is consistent like what you're
doing in one side versus the other but
we also want these to feel native like
if you are some we don't want like a
high goal like a high priority actually
for us is that the python inflammation
implementation someone doesn't come to
it and is like
why does this look like I'm writing our
code like we we do not want that to be
the feeling that anyone has on either
side right so we want it to be very
native feeling on both sides
okay well thank you so much Julia and
Isabel this was amazing and so great to
see all the questions from you all too
I'm gonna put the meet up slides and
documentation up there
just in case you missed that but again
the Meetup was recorded so it will be
available at the same exact YouTube link
that you watched from uh right as we end
the stream but if you have further
questions uh we'd love to hear from you
love to hear your feedback as well
I did just want to remind people we have
these meetups every Tuesday at 12
Eastern Time
and so we'd love to see you back
um thank you again for joining
um Julian Isabel you want to add
anything
I'll just say thank you for coming and
for your great questions
thank you all it was great to see
everyone online
thank you and I know there were a few
questions about
um how to evaluate our Studios
professional tools as well so I just
wanted to share this link here as well
so if you do ever want to chat about
products like rstudio connect you can
use that link or if you're ever just
curious if anyone from your team is
already using our tools and you want to
reach out to me very informally feel
free to just reach out to me on LinkedIn
as well and I'd be happy to to help
connect you
thank you all so much have a great rest
of the day
bye everybody